I kind of halted and things are at a
standstill right now
did you guys were you finished filming
this this current season or is that on
pause yeah we were able to finish the
season and we just been doing some
voiceovers and just for clarifying over
you know your the phone or whatever but
other than that we were able to finish
the season yeah we're hoping filming is
able to resume this summer depending on
what happens with everything you know
you know Jackson which three I got my
30th birthday coming out milestones so
we can also I think this summer to be
very exciting especially if the film
crew is able to capture some of the
adventures that we go on but we're also
you know prepared for it to me to be a
slower summer if things don't you know
if things just aren't able to happen but
yeah we're ready for whatever hopefully
hold the door private words at the farm
speed up and then we got our pumpkin
season at the farm in October that we
prepared for in the summer so a lot lots
of things to do lots of things to do
potentially but also we're just keeping
an open mind with everything and in the
meantime of course we have new episodes
of the show can you guys tease for the
rest of the season in terms of what we
obviously you know I feel like will
there be will we be taken along for the
ride when it comes to your mom and
possibly wedding planning yeah might so
exciting exciting season you know I'm
mom and Chris their relationship you
know changes in the sense of they get
engaged and so some of that and how that
all played out the family you'll get to
see some of our reactions towards that
bad news and then on my dad and Karen
just the farm development now that your
mom's off the farm have tension there's
tension there but um they're working
through it they stop to figure out my
mom's moved off the farm but they still
have to kind of like make the deal
happen for heard of these
disconnected and yeah there's definitely
tension they both work in very different
ways and you'll see a lot of that come
up from the upcoming season and so yeah
there's some tension there but they do a
good job I think working through it
[Music]